le 14ème meeting national Gilbert Bozon
débutait ce vendredi organisé par le
Club des enfants de Neptune cette
compétition de natation rassemble à tour
plus de 200 nageurs venant de toute la
France c'est plus du double de l'année
précédente l'enjeu pour eux se qualifie
au championnat de France élite open
reportage de Laura Chauvet
bonnet de bain sur la tête le nageur
polluvé Pansard se prépare pour la 14e
édition du Meeting Gilbert Bozon une
compétition à domicile pour le dossiste
qui est sorti de sa zone de confort lors
des épreuves de qualification ce matin
c'est 100 et 200 dos donc là j'ai
c'était pas forcément mes disciplines de
prédilection mais j'ai réussi à faire ce
que je voulais des temps plutôt corrects
et je suis content de satisfait de mes
performances au cinquant d'être papillon
j'ai fait 26
70 et au 52 j'ai fait 27 33 un score
bien mérité puisque ces derniers jours
d'entraînement n'ont pas été de tout
repos on revient d'un stage à Malaga on
est rentré mardi soir donc ils sont un
peu fatigués voire même très fatigué
est-ce que les championnats de France
sont dans 6 semaines donc c'est pas le
moment d'être reposé donc j'espère
qu'ils vont essayer de nager quand même
assez vite même s'ils sont fatigués par
avec entraînement qu'on a eu à Malaga
mais la concurrence est rude pour
prétendre au podium les nageurs ne
doivent pas relâcher leurs efforts les
nageurs ont des concurrents de leur
niveau puisque pour venir ou ici ou
meeting national il faut
rentrer dans une grille mais une grille
de temps qui n'est pas définie par nous
mais qui est défini par la Fédération
française de natation pour garantir la
qualité du meeting voilà donc ceux qui
viennent là savent qu'ils vont avoir des
nageurs de leur niveau et donc
l'émulation
il y a rien de tel et je dis toujours au
nageurs il y a que la compétition qui
prépare à la compétition
les compétitions ouvertes au public se
prolongeront jusqu'à la fin du weekend